and flicker full frontal nudity it's a
potentially nerve-wracking ordeal for
any actor or actress but these days it's
gotten a lot easier especially for males
to go nude on camera without showing
their actual groin region that's because
the use of Prosthetics is super common
now but did you know that in one now
Infamous scene an actor wore a
prosthetic member that was moved by a
gaming style controller by two men
standing 20 feet behind him and then
another actor actually thanked his
prosthetic during an awards acceptance
speech Let's strap on our uh thinking
caps and take a look at actors who have
recently worn NSFW Prosthetics on screen
fans of season two of The White Lotus
will certainly remember the scene early
on where we caught a little too much of
a glimpse of Theo James's character
Cameron it was a power play by the
ethically challenged character as he was
supposed to be privately changing into a
borrowed bathing suit but instead of I
don't know changing in the bathroom like
a normal person Cameron decided to
disrobe in front of his best friend's
wife Harper Harper played by Aubry Plaza
definitely did not finding an endearing
moment though spoiler it sort of did
come back into play in certain ways
later in the season regardless it
appeared that Theo had revealed his
manhood for the shot and people
including Jimmy Fallon went a little
berserk over it what in the what in the
good for you by the way oh my God and
while Theo enjoyed playing along with
Jimmy's compliments can't breathe
sometimes because the weight of it he
cops to using a prosthetic the truth of
it was thank goodness and apparently
Fallon's producer wanted to know if Theo
had hung on to the giant prosthetic
after shooting it was nine inches
another recent hit show Pam and Tommy
required the use of an assortment of
prosthetics for both of its leads in
order to physically match their
real-life counterparts first off was
Sebastian Stan who in addition to having
loads of fake tattoos put on to match
rocker Tommy Lee also had to have a
prosthetic for a certain legendary
appendage there's one scene in
particular that people will be talking
about for a long time and it's as funny
as it is bizarre and as anyone who has
seen Pam and Tommy can verify it's about
the furthest thing from a standard full
frontal scene in the infamous moment
Tommy has a full-on conversation with
his member why well because Tommy Lee
himself wrote about it it's in his book
that he wrote writer's uh sort of tipped
their hat to that the prosthetic was
actually a puppet that was mechanical
and took two people to operate the whole
thing was actually two men that actually
made it move from 20 feet behind me of
course there were plenty of scenes where
they didn't need Tommy's buddy to look
like he could move and talk but often in
those scenes Sebastian was required to
wear a thong and the prosthetic they
used for the scene I just talked about
was well too big so they had to craft
some other prosthetics for when he had a
thong on they also used a type of
stuffing called Packers for other scenes
with non-thong outfits so yeah that's a
lot of time and effort put on a uh
member of the cast Lily James also
donned Prosthetics when portraying Pam's
legendary figure and of course it takes
a long time in the makeup chair for an
actor or actress to be fitted with
prosthetics though Lily James admitted
there was at least some variation on
that yeah that would it depended on
outfit to the sort of like extent of
what I had to put on prosthetic wise but
even on light days it was apparently
pretty grueling however it was at least
three hours sometimes four sometimes
more you know what's not grueling
hitting that subscribe button just
saying Simon Rex didn't play a famous
rocker or Baywatch star in red rocket
but he did play a role that required a
prosthetic a former adult film star and
it probably won't be super surprising
that anyone actually playing a male
adult film star might end up donning a
prosthetic it's frankly a lot for anyone
to live up to so there's no shame in
your game if you needed a little help in
that role in particular Simon Rex
received rave reviews for it the acting
job not the prosthetic although he was
so appreciative of the job they did with
his prosthetic he literally gave it a
shout out when he won best male lead at
the 2022 film independent Spirit Awards
thank you
as far as I know that
Award acceptance speech with that
particular attribution but hopefully not
the last speaking of roles in the adult
film World Mark Wahlberg might have the
honor of wearing the most famous NSFW
prosthetic for his role in the movie
Boogie Nights he played fictional adult
film star Dirk Diggler who is equipped
with an incredibly impressive
um co-star but even for Wahlberg who has
certainly been involved in many a
wardrobe fitting over the years it was
far from a comfortable process I'm gonna
take off my clothes and they start
basically sculpting this thing around
you there was also the fact that it
wasn't exactly a clip-on Wahlberg had to
be fitted in it each morning they shot
and then was pretty much out of luck if
he wanted to take it off it was pretty
embarrassing then when you you have this
weird guy putting it on you you have to
wear it all day but obviously the
prosthetic meant a lot to mark because
he couldn't bring himself to let it go
after production on the film ended it
actually is the only prop that I've ever
kept from a movie and I don't know if
Chris Hemsworth hung on to his
prosthetic from from the movie vacation
but I'd like to think so because it
seemed like he was having a lot of fun
on the shoot as were his co-stars I
laughed the whole time it was one of
those occasions where a prosthetic is
there solely for humor and well mission
accomplished it was a team effort too
which is nice to hear we had the choice
of an eight inch and a ten inch and we
tried them both on him for all you guys
out there I hope this made you feel
better about your own body because you
now know Hollywood can be oh fake have
any thoughts about actors wearing NSFW
Prosthetics pop them in the comments
foreign